in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about segment congruence and
what we have here let's call this
statement 1 this is the definition of
line segment congruence or at least the
one that we will use two segments are
congruent that means that we can map one
segment on to the other using rigid
transformations and examples of rigid
transformations or reflections rotations
translations and combinations of them
now what we're going to see in this
video is that statement 1 is actually
equivalent to statement 2 or another way
of saying it is if statement 1 is true
then statement true is true and if
statement 2 is true then statement1 is
true or we can write it like this we can
map one segment on to another using
rigid transformations if and only only
if the two segments have the same length
so how do we go about proving it well
the first thing that we'd want to prove
is that if if a statement 1 is true then
then statement 2 is true so how would we
go about doing this and like always I
encourage you to pause the video and
have a go at it
alright now let's work through this
together and some proofs like this might
be difficult because they feel so
intuitive but one way to prove this is
to first say that by definition rigid
transformations preserve length so by
definition by definition definition
rigid transformations that's what makes
them rigid rigid transformations
preserve preserve length so if so if one
segment if one segment can be mapped
onto onto
a second segment with rigid
transformations with rigid
transformations transformations they
must have had the original the same
original length they must have had the
same original X they must have had same
original length or another way to say it
is then - is true then we can try to do
it the other way around so let's see if
we can prove that if - if statement two
is true then statement1 is true then
statement1 and want you pause this video
and have a go at that as well so let's
assume assume I have segment a B and
then I have another segment let's call
it C D have the same length have same
length so they meet number two the
number two statement right over there to
map to map a B on to C D all I have to
do I can do this in two rotations every
time I first will I will translate so
that a is on top of C so I will
translate translate a B so that point a
is on top of Point C and then the next
thing I would do is rotate rotate a B so
that point B point B is on top of point
and there you have it for any two
segments with the same length
I can always translate it so that I have
one set of points overlap and then to
get the other points overlap I just have
to rotate it I know that's going to work
because they have the same length so
I've just shown you if we can map one
segment on to another using rigid
transformations then we know they have
the same length and if two segments have
the same length then we know that we can
map one segment on to the other using
rigid transformations